earlier this week I had the chance to
sit down with forts of horizon 2 and
play through pretty much the first hour
of the game now this may come as a shock
but it's pretty fun actually it's a lot
of fun but let's get a little more
focused than that here are the three
biggest takeaways from my time with the
game I want to find out who's the best
driver
first it feels like much more of an open
world than forts of horizon-1 now it's
not just the fact that it's bigger it's
the fact that there's so much more to
the game than what you find on the
actual roads so let's say you're just
free roaming and you want to goof around
hey look it's a vineyard I think I'll go
destroy it and you can do that you can
ruin a poor winemakers entire livelihood
just because you wanted to see how well
a BMW z4 could spin doughnuts in the
dirt or because you wanted to take a
shortcut on the way to your next
objective or because you just wanted to
drive off a cliff but the real payoff to
all of this it's not goofing around sure
that's fun but let's remember that this
is a racing game now the payoff is in
the off-roading events these are just
insane driving through these big
expansive open fields as you trade paint
with other cars and race through the
trees it's a whole new dynamic from the
rally events in the first horizon which
tended to focus more on sticking to
pre-arranged dirt roads but this this is
off-roading freedom
second it's a much more customizable
game than the first horizon oh yeah
here's where we do the real serious
stuff see horizon 2 is the first of
these spin-offs to adopt the tuning
system from forts and motorsport so if
you're a hardcore racing fan not only
can you scroll through the difficulty
settings and disable all the assists you
can also get super granular with your
gear ratios your downforce and whatever
else you want to tweak on that new ride
of yours and on top of that there's this
whole perk system which lets you spend
skill points to unlock new abilities for
yourself like the first one that gives
you xp for banking skill chains so
between that the tuning and the driving
assists you should be able to add quite
a bit of personal touch to the whole
driving system and finally let's talk
about the story now if you know me you
know that the story was pretty much my
least favorite thing about the original
horizon it just tried so hard to be cool
to the point where it felt like some
marketing executives fever dream vision
of a music festival when I saw that
horizon 2 opens up with all these
cinematics naturally I got a bit worried
but I don't know the whole thing seems
like it's a bit more dialed back
compared to horizon one a few narrative
beats I saw were quick they they got the
point across they didn't overstay their
welcome and that's good but at the same
time I can't help but wonder why they
bothered with that stuff at all but you
know either way the story stuff was
pretty minor and didn't detract from my
enjoyment of the game
I can already tell that horizon 2 is a
lot of fun and I am totally ready for
the full release later this month
you
[Music]